prévenir pour mieux guérir on risque de
voir l'apéro périr preuve de mauvais
calembours que se passe-t-il à marseille
pourquoi les mesures sanitaires
drastiques qui étouffe actuellement le
monde de la restauration dans la cité
phocéenne continue d'être appliquée
alors que d'autres grandes villes
françaises y échappe depuis quatre jours
consécutifs les réanimations ne cesse de
baisser dans la deuxième ville de france
passant de 50 à 39 sur 90 lits un signe
encourageant qui aurait pu amener le
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand a
levé la fermeture des bars dans les
bouches du rhône
pourtant lors de son point de situation
du 1er octobre il n'en a rien été
dans ces zones nous prenons du coup par
nécessité des mesures de gestion plus
contraignantes encore pour freiner plus
vite et plus fort la circulation virale
nous ciblons précisément les milieux et
les circonstances à risque en
interdisant les grands rassemblements
cette fois ci au dessus de 1000
personnes s'appuyant sur les données du
système d'information national le cidep
le président du conseil général de la
région paca le républicain renaud
muselier le faisait remarquer le 1er
octobre même le fameux taux d'incidence
qui indique la force de propagation
d'une épidémie est en forte baisse sous
les 200 personnes par 100 mille
habitants désormais et pourtant les bars
de la métropole aix marseille restent
fermés tandis qu'ils sont toujours
ouverts à paris où le taux d'incidence
est plus fort dans sa dernière vidéo
datant du mardi 29 septembre le
professeur et épidémiologiste
marseillais didier rahout notait de son
côté une tendance de l'épidémie à la
baisse dans la cité phocéenne en cloche
aussi on est sur la pente descendante de
la cloche
qu'il s'agisse des cas détecté des cas
hospitalisés
l'augmentation des admissions en
réanimation ces derniers jours n'était
donc selon lui que le reflet de ce qu'il
se passait il ya 10
jour se basant sur les travaux du
professeur parisien vincent jarlier
didier rahout note par ailleurs une
différence notable de la sévérité de
l'épidémie au niveau de la mortalité
or le problème c'est qu'olivier ferrand
dans son point d'actualité du 1er
octobre présente des chiffres différents
aix marseille i est toujours présenté
avec un taux d'incidence a plus de 250
contrairement à paris alors que d'après
le système d'information nationale celle
inverse
autre point crispant le taux
d'occupation des lits de réanimation
dans les bouches du rhône
il est de 40 4% tandis qu'il avoisine
les 45 50 voire 55 % dans le val d'oise
la seine et marne et la seine saint
denis où les bars reste pourtant
toujours ouvert et il faut dire que ces
jeux de chiffres passent mal pour les
élus provençaux ces restrictions sont
vécus comme de lourdes sanctions
économiques infligé un secteur de la
restauration
déjà très fragile autant dire comme une
véritable injustice
olivier ferrand s'est pris les pieds
dans le tapis et ne sait pas comment
pouvoir s'en sortir
les décisions prises à marseille ne
peuvent pas être prises dans le reste de
la france
je lui demande de changer de position à
marseille on est en souffrance
économique
olivier ferrand a puni ceux qui ont fait
le plus d'efforts en matière de co vide
en france ce soir au vu des chiffres des
courbes et de l'absence totale de
nouvelles mesures dans le pays je note
qu olivier verront se soucie finalement
plus de la situation sanitaire à
marseille qu'à paris ou qu'à lille les
marseillais le remercier
le 30 septembre à 15 heures le tribunal
administratif a confirmé le droit du
gouvernement à garder les restaurants et
les bars fermés dans les bouches du
rhône
pourquoi donc ces différences de
traitement entre les bouches-du-rhône et
l'ile-de-france quoi le gouvernement
annonce t'il des chiffres différents de
ceux des sources officielles disponibles
publiquement
[Musique]